what is happening there reject nation
happy made the fourth to
you we are gonna watch a show i'm very
much excited to check out
the bad batch the star wars universe
carries on yeah i binge cloned wars like
right before mandalorian season two
everything's kind of jumbled in my mind
in terms of memory we'll see what i
remember
timeline by no means are we star wars
experts uh you know like i've only seen
the clone wars one time feel free to
educate us on anything
if we happen to miss something that's
that's an important detail but the bad
batch was in the
last season so you know like they're a
little fresh in my mind for the most
part either way i'm excited for this you
know it's
like it's gonna be the early days of the
empire and we haven't had a show that
really focuses on that just yet guys
subscribe click that notification when
our next reaction is up
also uh hit that like button helps out
the algorithm and of course
full length reaction watch along as we
stick with the time code although our
patreon page
cover a bunch of shows over there as
well where you got the option for both
reaction highlights like i see here on
youtube
along with watch along you know pick
whichever one you want to watch for
majority of the shows we got over there
thank you so much for being here thank
you to prathrom jindal for editing these
highlights for us
let's get into this over hour long
episode
it's gonna be something special
cinerate
i used to love battle droids so at this
point the time
order 66 has not been activated yet
here i'm here
it's caleb
is rebels okay they'll educate you and
then you educate me
oh this is so cool but you gotta see
these clones
they're different i heard his voice and
i was like i think that's it
ah they get your mom's boys
ah there you go
i don't believe it that's clone force 99
damn straight sir yes
huh
bad bats just took care of all of it for
you guys you're welcome
there you are little jedi you missed all
the fun
watching your team in action was the fun
care to introduce
your new friends caleb yes master this
is
wrecker hunter echo
tech actor crosshair the general will
not need
any of us the clone war may soon be over
we move fast good that's the only way i
know
i'm the deepest voice kid in the galaxy
i love how this feels like a direct
continuation
of clone wars but the way how clone wars
ended with
66. oh cool here we go
oh damn
oh wow you can see caleb's in there oh
damn
stay away from me damn they're not
affected at all
what just happened the calm channel is
repeating one directive
execute order 66. you know i heard that
too
cross hair you and i will track down the
kid and make sure nothing happens to him
oh it's so cool regaining like
caleb's origin with it oh that's so
awesome
he's close come on down kid we're here
to help
no liar
what are you doing following orders
don't even know what the order is good
news
dude may knows
take it easy kid i'm on your side
i'm so into this uh stay back
you killed her the others did
i'm just as confused as you are
no
beautiful shot where's the jedi
he didn't make it
he doesn't see any remnants i can't tell
if crosshair is just following orders or
if he
or if he's he's influence yeah so
maybe because they have like they're
like the defected ones
that's probably they probably didn't
install or 66 in them whatever mental
mind control inhibitor they have in
there
we completed our objective not every
objective
hunter let that jedi kid dude
an order is an order since
when none of this makes sense
those clones served alongside general
bulova for years
how could they turn honor like that
because of the regs programming
it's been well documented that the
kaminoans inhibited the cognitive
functions of clones to engineer them to
follow orders without question
obviously we are different they
manipulated pre-existing aberrations in
our dna
resulting in your brute strength cross
has sharp shootings
break it down for the audience enhanced
senses and my
exceptional mind my guess is we are
immune to the effects of the progress
were programmed
the damage you sustained on skacko miner
most likely wiped out all of your preset
behavioral modifications
you are more machine than man you lucked
out echo
good thing you were tortured for so long
it's really paying off right now
they pull that straight from revenge of
the sith galactic
empire don't talk so loud in the hallway
man
hello what's that
adolescent human female origins
my name's omega i was wondering when you
guys would come back
he is my medical assistant one with a
curious mind that causes her to wander
this day keeps getting weirder and i'm
sure we'll never daughter of all them
oh no oh god that's an origin story i
want to say
good old tarkin hello again
omega
check it out the defect squads got
themselves a new recruit
they're like more proficient than all
you guys who threw that
i did
stormtrooper food fights oh here we go
oh they're gonna kick all their asses
aren't they
oh never mind it's
a double tray it seems cool
boomerang
ah tarkin's gonna be on to them it's a
test
admiral tarkin's here he's the one
evaluating the clones
i'm going to not happen keep your
distance
something about her presence reminds me
of like filling that void of a young
ahsoka
in some ways we're not in trouble and
they want us to fight more
oh things smell so bad after all
oh i have no idea
a little bit it's dedicated so much that
i'm learning about all this
oh man a battle simulation
give us a real challenge you may begin
take the towers
i mean they're they're above average
when it comes to the clone troopers you
know so
this is taking way too long uh i hope
target's not up there going
we're set we're setting stormtroopers
switch to live fire oh tarkin
buddy they must protest i don't know
about this
they were not given a heads up about
that these training blasters are useless
that we improvise
why don't you memorize them i have
yep
have a tendency to veer from standard
combat protocol
yeah he likes
done that him go
you should have killed that jedi kid man
see what you got us into here
nice badass legit
hey wrecker wow
you and me both wrecker
yeah yeah you kill a kid
never letting that go
i've seen enough tarkin's going to go
touch himself
that was a very hot display create his
own little bad batch known to me
know why my mind just spiraling
tell me about clone force 99 well
there's hunter
crosstails how many of these enhanced
clones
do you present there's more than them
okay yet reports indicate they exhibit a
concerning level of disobedience in
disregard
they're too autonomous then they
executed order 66.
one would assume assume nothing only the
general's death is when you assume you
make an outside of you and me
so phrase i've come to live by we're not
dummy droids that much we agree
hey hey you have a mission for us
sir indeed we have tracked a group of
insurgents to the alderaan sector
if you neutralize this grave threat you
will be looked upon most
favorably as i assess the needs of the
imperial army
that's a good thing that's a good thing
hunter what is it that imperial officer
i think he has it out for you yeah no
[ __ ]
i don't trust him it's nothing to worry
about
then let me come with you oh it's okay
you're not a soldier it's dangerous it's
dangerous here too change takes getting
used to
you'll see and she's definitely going to
heed that advice
and so will hunter yep knocking 25 heat
signatures ahead but
zero droids tarkin said insurgents
not droids insurgent children children
out here what are you waiting for i
really want to shoot this old lady
stand down we are not alone
ah stand down
you heard him stand down
it's important to get both sides of the
story yes absolutely
gotta be diplomatic cross heralds
will turn bad at some like full on bad
certainly shake things up
these aren't separatists they're
republic fighters
i would talk and send us to attack our
own forces we refuse to fight
for an empire you saw herrera
he looks so cool right yeah the old ways
are done
can either adapt and survive or die with
the past
saw guerrero
tough son of a [ __ ] cross hairs just
just get on their side just be on the
same page
why are we debating this we need to
complete the mission
they sent us to eliminate innocent
civilians those insurgents are plotting
against the emperor
spying on us now jedi
oh my god she said not to return to
kamino
maybe she's right or maybe you should
just go right back to kamino
a state of heightened awareness is not
unusual for an enhanced clone such as
herself
good one tech talk and assume that meant
us
but echoes a reg the fifth is omega
no oh cool
what you waited until now to mention it
well i thought it was obvious i didn't
think she was the fifth one
disobeying orders again over a kid
she's one of you come on man she's one
of us
we're not leaving her there that's right
he did say
five that's right an echo is not
slipped it right under our head
i'm not authorized to be in here i
pack up the gear and take it to the
hangar we are official
don't touch me oh
hey bad man bad clone
bad club does she stay a kid or is she
like a newer one
yeah that's my question now yeah yeah
she's just gonna be forever young and
she's secretly like 50 years old
stick to the plan split up find omega
meet back here at the ship
and you better stick to the plant
crosshair someone keep an eye on him
please
i love the tension in the mood wait a
shot oh man
let's go oh
as expected thanks bud
i assume you know the punishment for
treason throw them in the bridge
oh the plan wasn't a total failure
you want to come with us or did we get
captured for nothing
i want to go with you how
touching god damn it man maybe he's the
odd one now maybe it's not actually echo
but they're forever fugitives once they
get out of there it's about to go that
way
i know it's not your fault
you can't help it ah
oh he's fighting it yeah
while the chip is not as active as a
standard clones
can you intensify oh no
fight it okay
come on crosshair i'll pour across here
the only one in the bunch yeah the only
one of the batch
huh this is a kaminoan facility
it was built prior to the clone wars
well how does that help us
because while these cells were
retrofitted to hold normal individuals
they could not possibly account for
someone like reckon
if you punch the correct spot right
this is so cool oh
hell yeah i'm so glad this is good i
know right
hit this here
a little harder
but i was actually going to suggest i'll
do it
it feels like she's on a video game
mission yeah
oh hell yeah omega resourceful
come on
let's make this quick i don't think
we'll have to go far
oh no oh man
is that damn it
oh
have you lost your mind we should have
killed that jedi it's been taken from
you
so cinematic no
the lighting
i'm gonna shoot the ceiling
crosshair would know how they would move
too
taking hits today
someone's overriding the controls
only one way out hunter your
move go
kid got angry i am omega kid got aim
no omega okay
oh cross hair
dude can't make a team out of six people
gotta lose at least one but maybe he can
be redeemed by season zen
from narrative standpoint i think it's
powerful because he makes like someone
who's hunting them more personal
mm-hmm and someone who knows them yeah
who can like
get in there and it was already in their
other strategies
until the empire's intentions are made
intentions
what do you think the intentions pay
attention to their actions this whole
time
i think they want to take over the
galaxy
you even listen to anything
conversations with admiral tarkin
maybe he's not grand admiral yet yeah
he's not his his
mania hasn't grown that large
strap in kit you're not gonna want to
miss this view
behold the magic of space tremble
wow beautiful yeah
the wonder that's right
flowning that was great transition we
got mics now
a lot of noise going on outside and this
is the discussion part of the video
so i was like let's just pull these mics
over here it has to be pillowy and soft
on your ears
here a whole bunch of other things being
picked up in the background here this is
like
two minutes later this wasn't a fancy
setup thing literally move these over
here
the arms down into frame and set up some
stuff on the computer
i really liked this a lot i loved it i
believe if
my memory serves me correctly i remember
learning that the character hunter was
inspired by billy from the movie
predator
hmm and i kind of feel like there's a
little bit of
that tone throughout i think the tones
because you got like this bad batch
characters
they all have their different
specialties hunter being the lead
character
i feel like there's a little bit more of
like adapting his sort of mood
throughout the rest of this episode i
don't know if you get what i'm saying by
that this sort of like deliberately
paced
on edge tension filled it does feel like
they're
like his name is hunter and it feels
like this is a like a little bit of
heist a little bit of haunted
well there's a sense of espionage you
know yeah and i mean in what they have
to do but also in the dynamics of you
know what
the various villainous forces are doing
they are being hunted and they are also
hunting throughout the episode and so i
feel like yeah that especially
suits the flavor and the tone because so
much of it i think is also about
watching the transition happen as the
clone wars end and order 66 goes into
effect and then them
realizing sort of oh it's like all the
clones are acting a little
funny and oh like all the higher ups
like tarkin's here and he's acting weird
too and they're not telling us
everything and so
it does a nice job of putting you off uh
putting you off ease and putting you on
your guard
as the episode keeps going from the very
beginning of this episode i think it's a
really cool complementary effect which i
was trying to insert during the reaction
because some people don't stick around
for the commentary part
season seven does end uh where you're
focusing on ahsoka
and rex offscreen is revenge of the sith
is happening
and a concerning innovator you know uh
all that jazz
here it picks up still like around the
event
right before order 66 takes place we
were seeing it from
the bad batches perspective and also
getting uh
caleb here or uh kanan and rebels kanan
right i think that's like the name i
don't
i don't remember the decision kanan
caleb is his original name
he's not confusing all right i don't
remember exactly where the kanan name
came from the second i was hearing his
voice i was like he kind of looks and he
sounds
yeah that's him and i thought that was
really neat uh kanan
is the original uh mentor
to uh ezra miller oh that's her bridger
yeah i remember a lot of names ezra
and ezra miller he's easier too i should
have done a re-watch of
all of it before going into this okay
he's an important character and it is
cool to actually
see how his storyline intersects
with the bad batches in terms of like
the origin of order 66 you know like you
see that
haunting element there of him having to
witness the execution of his master
but yeah i mean just think like visually
this whole episode is so beautifully
drawn out literally yeah and it's it's
mapped out uh great and they have such a
great uh tension
about it the whole time i think it's
neat because there'll be
things that you'll miss if you haven't
seen clone wars
or you know i've i've seen it there's
things that i'm sure
flew over my head no i caught all the
easter eggs
everyone got it all right every single
one they do a good job at establishing
like if you've really seen the movies
you'll know what's happening you know or
they do a really good job of catching
you up
on who the team is what their
specialties are and what their general
legacy is right now i mean they have to
it's and it's a necessary thing yeah i
think like i even
even as someone mean for me i'm like i
could i could occasionally use like
use refreshers all the time when it
comes to star wars i don't know yeah
just refreshed me but it does feel like
a continuation of
clone wars yet it's gonna be i think
more
focused more direct because in clone
wars even though it starts off with the
clone wars title you have a similar
narration
catching you up thingamajig which was
dropped in the last few episodes of
clone wars so maybe that won't continue
here maybe that was just to like help
establish you in the of the point in
time
where we're at at the beginning of this
of the scene yeah and the in the first
scene that guy with the most cheerful
voice ever
yeah like really serial talk yeah last
time on the bad batch
but having that there and having to feel
like a direct continuation yet
clone wars hops around between different
and maybe they'll do that here but i
don't get the vibe they are
in clone wars they they'll hop around
like a few episodes here
with anakin a few episodes here with
anakin and obi wan or or this is ahsoka
this is rex these are clones this seems
like it'll
pretty much be bad batch focus right
yeah i mean who they interact with
yeah the title i mean if we're just
going off the titles alone it would
suggest you know clone wars we're just
gonna
kind of jump around the various
perspectives of this overall situation
whereas bad batch you know and even
having that title
burn out and give way to the bad match
it says to me that yeah they are
definitely going to be
who we're following whose perspective
we're seeing or we're sort of seeing
from the inside
of the burgeoning empire but from you
know the ground
and and these characters who are unique
but they're also you know like
literally in the lion's den as it's
forming you know
which is a unique perspective to come
from and also to a really compelling
way to throw them force them onto the
run and also everything with crosshair
you know that makes it that much more
obviously like you said
personal and tense so you know i feel
like that too
having that piece of stakes will kind of
also anchor it from the antagonist side
that's removed so even if you're cutting
away
from them you're probably going to be
cutting to something that has to do with
him you know
well you'll have tarkin back here as you
know like there's there's ranks within
the empire so
they'll have tarkin where it seems like
he'll kind of be the big baddie for a
while
you know obviously like the ultimate
he's not the ultimate one but he's like
the big baddie who's
hunting them down and has a special
interest in them because clearly
it's like man if all the if you could
get like the clones to be
like the bad batch yeah just obedient
yeah
you got something special in your hands
in terms of an army right
yeah if you get them all to be cross air
and just augment all their inhibitors
but the one who's hunting them down that
being cross hair and i think the mystery
of how they built that up was
really good yeah really strong because
while the
first i believe it was the first four
episodes of season of the last season of
clone wars had the bad batch in there i
think the first episode of season seven
was the bad batch you still don't really
know them all too well like in terms on
a
personal level you know like of course
they go their way to you know flare them
up here because it's their own show but
they do such a clever job here like
hunter
at the very beginning you know he's the
badass leader of them
but yeah yeah you have your save the cat
hook with him because he's trying to
save this kid yeah
like all the course but i i love how
fish out of water they are
here the whole time oh yeah they're so
not in the know and they have no idea
what the hell is going on and they got
to play along yet they don't
either they don't like to listen to
orders they're going to play by their
own rules and they have their own moral
code when they're first
introduced it's when the clones are good
yeah in in the clone wars
their their clones are like good people
and they're kind of the you know the
rebels on the edges trust
these guys yeah like bad dudes that
seems like a liability yeah i don't know
if we should work with these guys yeah
the clone force 99 here it's instantly a
big flip
the clones are all bad
damn it's a clever flip yeah absolutely
and so i love the
the mood it strikes i don't know
wrecker's hilarious he's a character who
could easily be annoying but he's
hilarious yeah he's they they toe that
line quite nicely
and he does bring and two i mean it's a
it's a nice reminder because i feel like
especially with the bigger movies you
can kind of forget that and i don't want
to belittle star wars at all by saying
this but you know like
the original films were made with youth
in mind and they're supposed to be youth
accessible and
going back to something like this i'm
like oh yeah this is the more uh
youth oriented angle on it and it's fun
to get the humor in a character package
that way you know
at least for somebody who's yeah not as
well initiated and as comprehensively
versed in
this world you know it's something i do
appreciate as you know being sort of a
different
facet of the empire of star wars
entertainment
yes i think it did a great job on
reselling us
on why to follow them for a series i
liked them in clone wars and i was
excited at the thought of them having
their own show but i wasn't exactly sure
what it would be
yeah so i love this odd position of
choice they have to be in here
especially in their pilot episode yeah
like where
which side do we fall on we've been
fighting here with the republic
okay now we're the galactic empire we're
safe because we're clones
yeah um but is this right but we have to
make a choice whereas none of the rest
of them get to and even if we didn't
necessarily seem like the group to go
and strike out on
like a huge cause of you know defying
the basically the nazis you know like
it's cool to
throw them into a position like that too
where now they have to almost take on a
moral mantle just because they're pushed
against a wall and they have to make
both like the right decision to stay
alive but also like the right
choice like to do the right thing yeah
you know and i love how early
this is in the in the reign of the
empire because they're not even called
the the rebels yet yeah
yeah it's like oh you're republic okay
like the way that reaction was to that
moment because
like the war that comes to mind it's oh
they're rebels but oh they're not even
labeled that yet
yeah it's not even a thing yet because
we just got rid of the separatists
yeah now there's a galactic empire and
now we have um
who what will be the rebels you saw
guerrera being a big revolutionary part
of that that was great to get sagar back
i i believe we did see him um
in clone wars and i think it was like
the early parts of season five is when
we saw him
um i can verify that as true yeah
you're seeing early part of season five
but i i don't remember the storyline 100
clearly in my head but i have like
images i'm not true star wars man i know
i mean it's true
but i wonder because
i i also play jedi fall in order and saw
gerrera does show up in that but
he's in the likeness of a forest
whitaker in that film and that it's you
see him on kashyyyk i get the impression
we'll probably go to kashyyyk here
just based off timeline stuff at some
point so i wonder if
there will be like an evolution of his
look
in this specific one that's what this
series is actually for is to justify how
his look changed so
much how he became for his winner how
did ted turn into bob sagan
no it's exactly for that how did you
lose like your cool ass goatee and
haircut you're all like fit and stuff
and then
i thought like they had like the moral
debates on display
done very well and i love how they in
terms of writing
they saved the reveal of what was going
on with crosshair later because that
enhances
the dilemma they're in already that
enhances the choice
that's the struggle of what to do it
could easily get diminished by if it's
made clear up front like oh no it's the
thing it's order 66 going on and
crosshairs
yeah head right now whereas when it
becomes about the discussion of
are these orders okay or not yeah it's
more about your focus more on
that and crosshair being like a dick
about that she's just like oh yeah
it's the classic argument of like is it
the just should you blindly follow the
orders or should you object and i love
that they threw that detail in of oh he
he is having the inhibitor go off and he
is reacting to it and he's trying to
stifle it
it makes for good tension because at
first you're like oh he's the foil of
the group and he's the one to be there
to you know check everybody else who's
gung-ho and be like should we do this or
should we
stick to ours and so yeah then
transitioning that into an
actual sort of villainous turn obviously
sympathetically because it's not his
choice uh yeah it was was a nice build
across the episode because it was one
aspect that had me wondering throughout
like are they just trying to throw me
because you know
what i know about this group is you know
obviously he's one of the team on the
core team
uh so that made for yeah an effective
mystery and also a
nice emotional sort of oh no yeah
yeah it was really smart to reserve it
that way you could get the focus on the
theme
and it does still create more tension
with crosshair i mean omega knows the
truth
yeah yeah because she's special which is
a i can't believe that detail flew over
my head he said five
yeah i was the prime minister was that
five he said five and then i was
i just went with it and i was like oh
okay all right yeah and then like oh
wait a minute
echo that's right echoes
man he's just got that torture
you know that extra help from torture
well she does remind me kind of filling
in the void of uh of
of like how when clone wars introduces
socatano like the young
special every star female character
yeah you have her and then here but it
seems like she'll be
uh even more integral to a certain
extent because she's gonna be the new
crosshair
i get the impression she's a little bit
more like she has powers to unlock
yeah that are stronger than anyone else
in the bad but that's like kind of the
vibe they set up with her
yeah and what's cool too is that this is
such a dark moment in time to cut to
the beginning of a show uh for the star
wars world right
this is just a massacre happening right
now yeah this is like post
nazis have taken over for a star wars
show to like start off
right then and there and then the tone
itself is
you know fairly mature for like an
animated show
it's not as dark as i'd say the last few
episodes of clone wars but it's still
pretty dark
it's about an elite team of military
folk you know it's gonna get dark a
little bit
i mean you have your humor that does
come through in certain like you know
banter riffs certain character moments
especially with wrecker and tech
with her what they what they did smart
of is like star wars needs to have that
sense of wonder
yeah with her characters where he look
like it's almost
so literal to the point where when you
when she's looking when they go into
hyper speed
and then like the and how it reflects in
her eyes this
gorgeous shot yeah and but yeah that's
where you're getting
that sense of wonder right there yeah
it's great i think everything they're
setting up and the and
then where it takes place in time
there's you know i don't want it to be
so i don't want to be like bent on
filling in gaps necessarily because the
character seems so strong
and there's something so unique to
explore about these defected clones
uh who who can think for themselves yeah
i love
and also for the point in time where
they're at where it's like the second
you look upon them you're like no
clones bad you know yeah exactly no
we're not
you know so it's an interesting point of
time to have it this is the first time
we're
going to be dealing with a a series
rebels takes place a few years in i mean
kanan's all grown up by that point i
forget how many years and it's a few
years in
and then here this is right at the
beginning yeah you know it's like
not even rogue one has happened yet yeah
yeah yeah yeah this is the early stages
this is this is it's always i feel like
this
won't happen yet i don't know actually i
feel like rogue one one of the timeline
i feel like rogue one would be at least
on the near horizon
no no because uh in rogue one
no the leia was already yeah there's
already a resistance
has just become dark yeah i'm trying to
keep track of the timeline yeah rogue
one hasn't even happened yet yeah yeah
yeah
maybe we'll get into the early days of
uh
is it galen or so early
yeah so maybe we'll see them show up
here at the death star
evolution of the death star oh yeah you
know that'd be pretty neat
because we don't really see that happen
in rogue one yeah and then you could
actually witness that here and then it'd
be cool they got mads mickelson back
dude i mean that's the funny thing about
some of these series especially is like
yeah now we're gonna have we got the
mandalorian which is like okay what
happened between the original
trilogy and the sequels and then we have
this series it seems like what
directly happened between revenge of the
sith
and a new hope what happened between all
that let's do this show for that
yeah it's gonna it's gonna be
interesting to see like the actual
development of them
yeah and i mean if anything precedes the
you know i've seen some of the clone
wars now but not
enough of it to really feel like i i
have a great
understanding of the true breadth of the
show but something about the show that
its reputation seems to carry along with
it
is the fact that they do explore these
themes and use the characters to
confront you know in a way that again is
broadly accessible these questions of
you know
wrong and right and duty and following
orders and these you know complex
sinister machinations that people can
especially in positions of power can
thrust on other people and so yeah to
have a show that is
at the onset of this empire seems like
you could also do some pretty
interesting and pretty i don't know
relevant and worthwhile
subtext along with your cool adventure
stuff
you know and it might tie into the
mandalorian directly because
uh the whole thing with they meant to
have the thing about clones or the the
camino people
who are in there at least people with
the camino patches
man this channel's like star wars their
own like no wonder you dedicate your
whole channel yeah
this is so much you gotta keep up with
them right i remember this correctly
other fandoms are not as intense
to really feel like you have a
comprehensive uh
vocabulary form there's just such a
timeline to obey here
yeah one star wars canon is like three
other canons so yeah i mean it could it
could tie in
yeah uh to it all because obviously they
created more than just clones there
i don't know what they're called camino
wins
yeah the prime minister the way how they
seem to have things where they don't
even fully seem to trust the empire yeah
at least the prime minister doesn't
you know this chara this character right
now doesn't so
i wonder it seems like they're setting
up for some conflict there to happen
between them and
and the empire oh yeah i mean everyone's
sort of watching to see what the
empire's deal
is it seems like now that they're
lording around and trying to take hold
of the galaxy
this is awesome i'm really excited for
this i thought it had a great pulse a
really cool
tone to it all and a lot of fun a lot of
fun a lot of great visual language it's
very like there's
a fast 70 minutes it felt very cinematic
a lot of new zealand accents
yeah dude yeah one axis are all that one
guy
no i know even she's got that same
accent yeah
that's when they should have gotten more
morrison back too i had to play this
voice over
more more than he we did the motion
capture
shrunk the model way down and you're
supposed to see fanuc chan at some point
in this series
so for a second at the end of the
episode i was like oh is that who
they're talking about but then they're
like ah
i know a guy and so i was like okay well
then i guess we got to wait for finish
sharon carter the power broker that's
right i know a guy
sharon carter maybe they'll go with that
too maybe they trying to throw us
because
hey if anyone could be a dude like we
learned a good burger maybe anyone can
be a guy
sure that all right guys well the bad
batch what did you guys think
personally loved it that was really
great i was super into that
episode too subscribe click that
notification bell hit that like button
last but not least
i want to shout out a man named eric
horstmann eric recently
got a haircut oh i hear he's looking
good no
actually you know eric you gotta have he
sent us a photo
did you cut your head hair or show the
photo or did you like
trim you know the rest of your body hair
but i gotta see
look how sexy it is and a fresh shave on
eric horstmann look at you
all and also it's his birthday in a few
days
and i found out during mandalorian he
binged
clone wars and rebels and of course man
lauren and
out of all the fandoms the one that he's
most into is star wars
dude so i wanted to make sure that
considering that this is the show that's
honing in on star wars this month
to immediately wish you a happy early
birthday here until you've got a sexy
haircut yeah
the f word out here i love the f word
too
and you eric horstmann i love you more
than any word
could ever communicate should have ended
on the f4 yeah you gotta know when to
end
we gotta know when to hold them when to
hold